كانت
عالمهم ولدت الكسندرا في بيروت تريسي
والطفل الوحيد لبول نجار
وفي سن الثالثة ماتت في
بيروت ، وانتهت حياتها بانفجار
مزق الكثير من
الأرواح.  لا أعرف
ماذا
ثم ضربت رأسي أيضًا
ثم غطيتها
وكان لدي بابان وسقف آه
والصدمات التي تعرفها على ظهري
ورأسها كانت الصدمة على رأسها كبيرة جدًا
لدرجة أنها تسببت في
وذمة  تضرر دماغها
كثيرًا ، لذا فإن
هذا ما جعلها تمر على
هذا الزوج من رواد الأعمال الشباب الذين أخذوا
الإسكندرية إلى مظاهرات العام الماضي
للمطالبة بلبنان أفضل
لا يزالون في حالة صدمة ويأس
تعرضنا للاعتداء والقتل في منازلنا ومنزلنا.
المأوى فقط
أو مكان الأمان الذي كنت تعتقد
أنه
لا يزال موجودًا ولم يعد لديك بعد الآن
، فالكثير من
الإصلاحات جارية في
الحي الذي يقيمون فيه بجوار إصلاح الميناء ،
ربما يكون الإيمان بدولة
تسقط  rt
بطرق عديدة
لا يستطيع الناس في لبنان الاستمرار في العيش في
دولة إجرامية ، أعني أنه لا يمكنك العيش
في بلد بعد الآن حيث
تكون الحكومة والبرلمان
ضدك وما زلت آمل
أن يكون الاختلاف الوحيد على ما أعتقد هو أن
الغضب الذي نعيشه اليوم
ينمو بشكل كبير
والواقع يضربنا ،
إنها الفرصة الأخيرة لدينا
بول وتريسي مثل الكثيرين الآخرين الذين
يفكرون في
الاستسلام والانتقال إلى الخارج ، لقد أصابهم الواقع في
لبنان بشدة.